jazakallah now we have the second part
of the program the rebuttal session may
I call upon Pastor Rockne to present his
rebuttal for 15 minutes
Pastor Rockne thank you doctor as a kid
for your point I saw a lot of illogical
discussion some of the things missed the
spirit of the word in many many
different so badly went illogical is
difficult to even discuss it but just a
few points and making it are not
commenting on everything a few points
I'm just bringing about because my
purpose here is not to win an argument
my purpose here is to present solution
for your life from sin Jesus the
crucified that's my person even if I
lose the argument okay that's my purpose
here all right
now number one is about talking about
embarrassing thing in the Bible is this
the Bible is so faithful in the truth is
like a faithful mirror if I have ugly
face my mirror will tell me you're ugly
if I have handsome face my mirror will
tell me you are handsome Bibles like
that that's why it represents both sides
of people it shows the sin and disgrace
of people to what extent people sin
against God
at the same time it shows to what extent
people could be pleasing in the sight of
God that's why the Bible is a balanced
record of human condition you will not
tell you simple a wonderful man never
made mistake no he'll show you the
faults of simple you look at other
literature even Islam and other
literature they make a man like God
Jay show him so perfect never made him
stick only Jesus never sent okay shows
Paul his good points is by he was so
bad-tempered I would never want simple
to be my CDA pastor you see he had a
fight with his pastures he had fight
with the Peter I think right about food
or something John right and so many
other things I would never like show you
both sides many other things the the the
prophet the servant of God Joseph in his
secret life he was a practicing
domination he had a cup of divination he
was a wonderful servant of God where he
had a weak point he was seeking the the
secrets through divination it's it is it
is not true so many aren't so many
people they have the good points they
have their bad points the Bible show you
that no one is perfect
sure is it a good point and the bad
points Jesus is the only one who never
sinned against God the Father even that
when he was a small boy he disobeyed his
parents but later he followed them they
he did not accompanying them as it was
expected for my young boys 16 years old
or 12 years old then when they came back
and rebuked him he followed them he was
learning he was good as a man he was
learning the Bible says in the book of
Hebrews he learned he learned obedience
that means he was less and he learned
that is the natural Jesus but as far as
sin he never sinned against God okay so
the Bible is a faithful record good and
bad you see you want to see how man can
be read the Bible you won't see how
wonderful man can be read the Bible a
criminal like Paul can be Saint Paul God
can make any one of us like that this is
a simple uneducated fisherman can be a
leader of the world read that in the
Bible you don't need a PhD you don't
need some MSC you don't need some degree
you read what what what John didn't
order ordinary man without education you
would he lead the whole world okay so
that in terms of
looking at the Bible second thing the
Bible's full of symbolism also many ways
God talks about many things and
symbolism right that's one thing
concerning the concerning that capital r
and small are in the dictionary i have
not examined that point but from doctors
akise words i I get it
resurrection with capital I is given as
an example of resurrection and I think
he misunderstood it he resurrection is
rising from the dead comma an example
resurrection of Jesus from the dead
capital R that was this example is
misunderstanding of the sentence I don't
think it is a religious point of view
it's just example most dictionaries give
you an example with the word so I don't
think it's something to do with we
Christian take capital R makes it
resurrection of Jesus and small our
resurrection something else I don't
think it's leather it's not that with
his misunderstanding of that way right
now another point he says crucifying the
commandments but Paul talking
particularly not the commandment itself
he's talking about what the commandment
has passed judgment on me because I am a
sinner that list of my judgments because
of the commandments that's the one that
fell on Jesus on the cross it is not not
crucifying the Bible or aspiring God's
word that is that is meaningless in
logical you know though the law is holy
and pure and the law was meant to expose
sin not to heal sin but to expose sin
but Jesus came to heal sin okay so it is
not crucifying the commandments the
crucifying the curses and the punishment
that the commandment spells against me
that list which says I have to go to
hell you know that is the one which is
crucified with Jesus it's the cursed
that was crucified Jesus received curse
on himself okay about Jesus awesome did
he the whole Bible is dr. Zook is saying
that nowhere and the Bible says Jesus
rose from the dead I was so shocked to
hear that now I would I would it took me
just one second to locate it and my
pastor located you could read it
sometime
something in like example Matthew 28
verse 6 read a little before laughter
later and concerning
you look at Revelation chapter 1 verse
18 Christ through the spirit he talks
about himself I was dead now I am Alive
I was dead now I'm alive
there is no philosophy about it there
was a dead man and now he's a live man
no nothing nothing playing in words or
some Greek word or something very simple
now next thing is talking about being
confused about whether this one looks
like Jesus there's a lot of mystery
about the new bodyguard promised to
those who died in Christ and a little
bit revealed about it number one Jesus
walked through the walls the doors were
closed he walked through the walls that
new body is able to overcome the natural
things number things that body looks
like is able to hide itself see Jesus
walk with two disciples after he rose
from the dead their eyes was prevented
from recognizing him to the way of
Emmaus and then he explained to them the
scripture explain to them scripture and
then we came to the house he broke bread
then the eyes are open and this is Jesus
not only Mary Magdalene did not
recognize him there are others who did
not recognize him till the point he
wanted to reveal himself then they
recognized him it looks like that body
had something very special
it can change its form and why did why
did Jesus show his hand he wanted to
show something special on his hand it
was a there was a hole in his hand see I
am the one see look the Pierce I'm Jesus
see I'm Jesus you he showed them her he
showed them aside also because the
soldier kissed him on his side see I'm
Jesus I'm not a different one this body
having the mark of the Cross the mark
which I received it looks like this body
even though it's a new body but it has a
semblance of the whole body mystery we
don't know anything about the new body
but we know it is supernatural body it
has a new glory it's a greater glory and
it resemble it is able to - - you could
say that that is brother Rockne when the
resurrected body but at times I can't
you can't recognize me I can I can just
walk through the wall III and there are
marks on body I can show you see this is
my marquee remember there was
macchia see that is me looking something
special that's that word Jesus Jesus
were trying to say that secondly in
concerning their to being big it's a
very clearly written Bible the tomb
belongs to a rich man a rich man will
not go to a cheap small room he will
have a nice spacious place for his full
family it's not a question Jesus living
inside the tomb you won't go and live
inside the tomb in a mock Boston
that's not a good place for him yeah it
is very clearly rich you mentioned that
the two was provided by a rich man and a
rich man you expect him to have a nice
big tomb for his full family members
second thing you just would like to
remind you it was the custom from the
time of Abraham to bury the dead in a
cave not in the dust in some cases
people were buried in the dust some
papers sometimes they were cremated but
mostly people were put in a cave Abraham
and his wife Sarah they were put in a
tomb which is a cave it was not buried
in the dust
so this rich man provided a stone cave
fitting for a rich man big size ANOVA
now you may say why the stone was was
open the answer very simple it is very
clearly mentioned the angel of the Lord
removed the stone when one of those I
think Mary Magdalene or some other one
came a mighty angel removed the stone
and the earth shook and the two soldiers
both frightened and fell down like a
dead two men and the angels told these
two women you don't be a scale it's not
meant for you to be scared
it is only for something I'm just
putting my own words it is meant for
this fellow to be scared enough for you
I have just removed it to show you look
he's not in the tomb see the tomb is
empty that well it is it's the tomb was
empty that was the purpose of removing
the stone to confirm to them that his
body is not inside his body is not
inside that the the clothes fitting a
grave is not fitting for him the clothes
fitting the gray for the grave that is a
white cloth they wrapped the people now
nowadays at those days I don't know it's
not suitable for him just kept aside for
the decided Sultan is folded aside so
that is concerning the two
is big yeah okay the next point is
concerning John other prophets Jesus
said like Jonah was in the - in the wave
three days and so on so Jesus did not
say I'm going to be put in the whale's
mouth he did not say I'm going to be in
the whale's mouth and the way will take
me three days in the sea he did not say
that he said like his similar to as an
example of Jonah
I will also be three days in the bottom
of earth if you only take it literally
did Jesus go and and in the whale mouth
no he was in a cave in a in a cave which
is considered to be a graveyard McCory
Stan it was a symbolism just like Jonah
was three days in the mouth in the
stomach of a whale so I will be also
buried in a tomb three days second thing
it is mentioned in the Bible on the
third day he rose it doesn't
specifically say 24 hours and so many
minutes in so many say on thirty heroes
so whether he rose one hour before when
our it's not mentioned what time he rose
just mentioned that they weren't early
and I found all the heroes there's no
specific time mention to him and finally
I think my time is over
finally I don't need the four minutes
yes finally I want to give you one point
I just give you one point it is written
in the Bible the privilege of seeing the
miracles of Jesus rising from the dead
let me see him after he rose I mean the
other way is not for everybody it's only
for those who believe for 500 of them
twelve and 120 and some totally
approximately 500 the whole Jewish
nation because of their unbelief
unfaithfulness rejection of God's
purposes they did not have the privilege
to see Jesus rising from the dead they
they did not see Jesus alive after his
death so you two today don't harden your
hearts and go the way of unbelievers
because God will reveal himself to you
if you go the way of faith receive the
words by faith simple faith pure faith
receive him as a gift from God he will
reveal himself to you if you had in
yourself you say this coma is twisted
white and that come as lucid left and
then you'll end up like the Jews being
rejected don't do that
receive him tonight soft in your heart
he you will receive forgiveness of sin
and resurrection from the dead at the
appointed time thank you thank you
Pastor Rockne about one minute left
may I now call upon dr. Zakir to present
his rebuttal for 15 minutes
alhamdulillah what's a lot was salam
other suli lavalla ali wasabi h main am
a bad house will diminish shaytan al
rajim bismillah ar-rahman rahim what
cool jaw chuck was a karate in Allah but
Allah cannot Buca bismillah r-rahman
r-rahim not Bashar al-asad me well silly
me why Allah looked at the Malay Sonny
yes totally respected pastor of me and
he said that I spoke everything
illogical as though he's going to give a
logical replied all of them and he did
touch on few of the fourteen points that
I mentioned a few of them which I reply
inshallah to each and every and you'll
be the judge who is illogical me or the
pastor the pastor said that the
definition in the dictionary having
checked but they are grieved that I
speak truth the capital are called the
dictionary Jesus Christ peace be upon
him was risen from the dead for
resurrection yes to rise
I don't tell pastor to agree with
additionally because he may not agree
with the history I may not agree but he
has to agree with the Bible st. Paul
says that in 1st Corinthians chapter
number 15 verse number 44 that
resurrected bodies ha Spiritualized
Jesus Christ peace be upon him says in
the Gospel of Luke chapter number 21
number 36 that the resurrected bodies
the angel eyes their spiritual eyes
does he believe in Jesus or no peace be
upon him so according to Jesus peace be
upon him for him to be resurrected he
has to be a spirit not a live body and
all the 14 point
mentioned proves that he was alive he
said that milling to the cross the Rhine
the commandant who said that
Paul not die Paul in Colossians chapter
number 2 verse number 14 which went
against the teaching of Jesus Gospel of
Matthew chapter number 19 was summer 16
and 17 who says keep the wrong
commandment I agree with Jesus peace be
upon him if you want salvation keep the
line commandment paul says nearly to the
first and faster sell all your good deed
i useless if no crucifixion Bible is
less than two fights and I prove there's
no crucifixion in the Bible this is
Christ people did not die
point number three said I said show me
one verse in the Gospel where Jesus
Christ peace be upon him is mentioned as
he is resurrected
not a single he quoted Gospel of Matthew
chapter 28 was number 6 he said and I'm
reading it he is not here for He is
risen as he said come see the place
where the Lord lay he is risen
it is not said that is erected resent
means he is alive I sleep and I rise
does it may have resurrected doesn't
mean that the pastor said he saw a girl
according to him she was dead the
doctors he says according to Jesus peace
before she was here she comes back to
life what she'll have erected posture no
she was resuscitated Jesus peace be upon
him was not resurrected from the dead on
the cross he was resuscitated point
number four he says the Bible says Jesus
peace be upon him walk through the world
no where is the mention the Bible it's
an assumption it's an assumption
no where it is mentioned in the gospel
walkthrough it's an assumption which we
can clarify if you know the background
which time doesn't permit Jesus wanted
to show his hands and feet why to show
the holes who's saying that pastor not
the Bible Gospel of Luke
number 24 verse number 37 faith that
behold my hands and feet it is I myself
see my hands and feet it is I myself for
a Spirit has no flesh and bones he
doesn't say see the mark on the handles
of nails that's what he see that's what
Thomas wanted Thomas wanted to see in
the upper room he shows to say I am NOT
the spirit to prove what he was not
resurrected point number six he says
that the tomb was big because it was a
rich man's tomb which already said in my
talk
it was the tomb of rich and influential
you Joseph of Arimathea in height that
wine number seven why was the stone
removed and the pastor said the angel
removes the stone
I didn't ask who removed the stone I
asked why was it removed and the pastor
said to show me the people that Jesus is
not dead if I agree with you for sake of
argument to show to the people Jesus
since before was not there why was it
necessary for the winding-sheet to be
unbounded the question is stuck together
stone removed and binding sheets and
Vaman it was unbound and placed it is
mentioned in the Gospel of John chapter
20 then it was unknown and kept even
Gospel of Mark chapter number 16 which
there's no plan the only answer is
because Jesus Christ peace be upon him
he was alive and because the other life
he had to unwind the sheets as well as
move the stone he said that Jesus is not
going to the will peace be upon him well
- a Jesus his English was very clear
Jesus Christ peace be upon him says in
the Gospel of Matthew chapter number 12
was number 38 to 40 that as Jonah was
three days and three nights in the belly
of the whale so shall the Son of Man be
three days and three nights in the heart
of the earth
Jesus case we would not say he will be
three days and three nights in the belly
of the whale I think you cannot
understand the plain English with Jesus
said as Jonah was three days and three
nights in the belly of the whale so
shall the Son of Man be three
then three nights in the heart of the
earth so where is the question of he
going in the value of the will it's
plain English like Jonah was in the
belly of the whale soul shall the Son of
Man be in the heart of the earth Jonah
was alive
so Jesus Christ peace be upon him to
fulfill the prophecy even he has to be
alive but the Christian says he was dead
so for him to fulfill the prophecy he
has to be alive the pastor said time
factor and I do agree
now the gospel says he rose on the third
day so he fulfills the prophecy of time
factor and there are other Christian
missionaries who when I spoke to they
said let's see as pastor said wonder
doesn't mean 20 for us and for sake of
argument you can agree and there was a
missionary told me that if I go to
Newark two o'clock in the afternoon
Monday afternoon and then leave from New
York next day early in the morning and
if someone asked me how many days have I
stayed in Europe I will say two days
technically is wrong but for sake of
understanding I'm a Buddhist though he
did not even spend 24 if he says two
days he can't take it for sake of
argument the Bible says I found a pastor
at Oh agree with him
Jesus Christ peace be upon him rose on
the third day part of a day can be taken
as a full day so if I agree with pastor
go and go into the details you know when
was he put into the tomb late in the
evening on Friday if he says early in
the evening I agree for sake of argument
he says afternoon I agree he says
suppose that Jesus Christ peace be upon
him did not leave the tomb early in the
morning on Sunday he left in the
afternoon
I agree so Jesus Christ peace be upon
him was part of the day take it as a
whole he was Friday
one day Friday night Saturday day
Saturday night Sunday morning even if
you stretch and give you a word on there
it comes with three days and two nights
the sign of do not even say as Jonah was
three days in the belly of the whale so
shall the Son of Man be three days in
the heart of the earth it's a
as Jonah was three days and three nights
so shall the Son of Man be three days
and three nights in that of the earth
how much of it three then tonight he
does not till the end three night
whatever gymnastics we'll try even if
you ask I'm trying to help you you can
never prove from the Bible it is three
days and three nights never and if a
Christian missionary tells me that he
goes to New York two o'clock in the
afternoon leaves next day in the morning
it is two days I'm ugly but if he says I
stayed in New York for two days and two
nights I will tell him a liar is a big
liar maximum you can fish two days the
figure of his part of the day is a full
day for sake of activity but he can
never say to day than tonight if he say
that he's lying and he says the last
point says that no one saw Jesus Christ
peace be upon you my life which have
proved in my talk and I've given
fourteen points which we touched on a
few which have again clarified logically
that Jesus Christ peace be upon him was
alive that means according to st. Paul
according to Jesus Christ peace be upon
him upon the Oxford Dictionary a corner
where traditionally he was not crucified
miss Duvall's he resurrected if he's not
crucified no crucifixion no and in his
talk
Pasteur said and explained very well in
the talk about the original sin and he
said that every human being and
according the teachings of the church
every human being is born in sin every
man child has the taint of the original
sin though original sin which he
described in rightly says what he
described but the reduction is not
logical he said that Adam and his peace
be upon them they disobeyed God and they
ate the forbidden fruit from the
forbidden tree therefore Almighty God he
punishes them and he says that removes
them from paradise isn't that enough it
further seasoning of the reference it's
Genesis chapter number three verse
number 16 he says that you
we shall toil in labor and a woman you
shall be the desire of the husband and
you shall be labor pains pregnancy the
curse of the Bible
after that the Christians say that every
child that is born from the time of Adam
is the opponent till the last child born
till the end of the world is born in sin
I am asking a question
when Adam peace be upon him eat the
forbidden fruit did you ask me did he
ask me for eating no he may have asked
the pastor I don't know didn't ask me if
you didn't ask me why should I be
responsible why illogical is God
illogical no and they have the system or
treatment of sin that God sent His only
begotten Son beloved son for sacrifice
so that he can sacrifice for the sin
let's see what does the Bible have to
say about that they talk about atonement
of sin @gs guys gave his life for the
sin of humankind and it says anything
and the Christian mission he's also
saying that you know the soul that
sinneth it shall die it's mentioned
twice in the Old Testament Ezekiel
chapter 18 verse number 20 Ezekiel
chapter number 18 verse number 4 the
soul that sinneth it shall die but if
you read Ezekiel chapter 8 in verse
number 20 that's not the end of the
worst it is only the stacking of the
worse the complete was safe the
Christian missionary says the soul that
sinneth shall die therefore every human
being is born in sin therefore who
believe in the crucifixion to get
salvation the complete verse says as
they kill chapter 18 verse 20 the soul
that sinneth it shall die but the son
shall not bear the iniquity of the
Father neither shall the father bear the
iniquity of the son the righteousness of
the righteous shall be upon him the
wickedness of the wicked shall be upon
him but continues next was chapter 18
was 2105 key at continuances but if the
person turned away from the sin and he
does all that is lawful and right he
shall live he shall not die who says
that Bible Old Testament as a key
chapter number 18 was number 20 21 you
shall not die if you Rachel did you
shall not die
peace be upon him said if you want
salvation keep the laws and Commandments
it is Paul who says that if Christ is
not risen from the dead our preaching is
vain and your faith is vain and I've
proved that Jesus Christ peace be upon
him was not really crucified and people
him asked me that do Christians have one
particular view only about restriction
it's a misconception that all the
Christians have only one view that Jesus
Christ peace be upon him was really
crucified it's a misconception because
there are biblical Christian scholars
who say that Jesus Christ peace be upon
him did not die on the cross he was put
on the cross but you have brought down
he was alive in early Christianity there
are no less than seven sects which
believe that instead of Jesus there was
somebody else put on the cross it's
known as the substitutional theory the
early Bohemians we believed in that the
car pockets are Christians they believed
in that the Naza had believed in that
the Corinthian they believed in that the
Christians many effects believe that
instead of Jesus Christ peace be upon
him somebody else was put on the cross
he feels the gospel of barnabas
castamere not agree with that he was a
contemporary of Jesus peace be upon him
an eyewitness he says that instead of
Jesus peace be upon him Judas was put on
the cross if you read the scrolls of
Nietzsche Hammadi it says Jesus Christ
peace be upon him was not crucified all
Christians I didn't say these things in
my talk because pastor will say I don't
believe in the Gospel of Barnabas I
don't believe in the school of nijem
body so what does he believe in he
believes in the Bible so I prove from
the Bible that Jesus Christ peace be
upon him he was not crucified and they
say that Jesus Christ peace be upon him
he died for the sins willingly he gave
if you read Gospel of Matthew chapter
number 27 verse number 46 and the Gospel
of Mark chapter number 15 verse number
34 when Jesus were put on the cross he
cried out Li Li la Mohabbatein
li li lama sabachthani which means all
God o world why has all forsaken you
imagine Jesus Christ peace be upon him
Willie
on the cross and then grime on the cross
all god oh what if I had all forsaken me
proving that he did not go willingly on
the cross why should we cry and every
Bible you pick up whether the English
Bible whether the Hebrew Bible whether
you pick up the Marathi Bible or don't
do Bible the original Hebrew statement
is there li li lama sabachthani and then
the translation o god o world by health
office again me to prove that JFK's
peace be upon him did not bring me gone
and I would like to say in the
conclusion the jessica's peace be upon
him he was not crucifix was crucifix it
and I like to give the translation of
the words which I decided the beaming of
my talk from Sri surah chapter 17 verse
81 he says what will jar Huck was asked
about it in neuropathy lock on ahsoka
went through the whole again falsehood
falsehood parishes for falsehood is by
its nature born to perish worid are not
hungry Larry Bellamy
now we would have the third session of
today's evening that is the open
question and answer session to derive
maximum benefit in the limited time of
approximately 50 minutes that we have
for the question-and-answer session the
following rules should be observed your
question should be only on the topic was
Christ really crucified questions out of
the topic will not be entertained kindly
state your question briefly and to the
point this is not a lecture time for the
questioners pastor Rockne and dr. Zakir
should answer comprehensively and their
answers should not exceed five minutes
only one question at a time may be asked
for your second question you would have
to stand at the back of the queue again
and await your second chance for mics
have been provided in the auditorium for
the questions from the questioners -
next to the stage for the gents and - in
the rear for the ladies if you wish to
ask a question to Pastor Rockne you may
please line up behind the mic which says
question for Pastor Rockne for example
the question Mike on my left next to the
stage is for Pastor Rockne for the gents
similarly the mic on my right-hand side
next to the stage is for questions for
dr. Zakir similarly in the ladies
section it's written on the mic a slip
written questions on slip papers which
are available from our volunteers in the
aisles would be given secondary
preference and only if time permits
kindly state your name and profession
before putting forward your
so that the speakers have an
appreciation of your level of question
and give an appropriate response we will
allow one question at a time in a
clockwise rotation alternately addressed
to each speaker maybe have the first
question from the gents on my right for
dr. Zakir
my question is to dr. zakir naik jesus
was crucified for the sins of humanity
can a person be as someone else since
there's a question that can a person be
crucified for somebody else's sin and
it's a very logical question part of it
I had covered in the rebuttal and I
prove from the Bible that according to
the Bible the Book of Ezekiel chapter 18
verse number 20 and 21 says that the
soul that sinneth it shall die but if he
turns away from the sin and the
righteous did he shall not die and
neither can the Sun bed the nuclear the
father neither the father can bear the
nuclear the Sun means I cannot be
responsible for my father's sin neither
can my father be responsible for myself
a similar message of here in the Quran
in several phases if you read in surah
anaam chap number 6 was number 164 in
stress era chap number seventeen verse
number 15 it's mentioned in so a father
chap number 35 verse number 17 in surah
az-zumar chapter 39 verse number seven
in several places it says that no bearer
of burdens can bear the burdens of
another same method as the dakhil
chapter 18 verse number 20 that means
sin cannot be inherited pastor in his
talk that be an example of Abraham peace
be upon him that God asked his son to be
sacrificed and I do agree with the
pastor he won't detest him and at the
last moment he puts a lamb that means
Almighty God he's just
he wants to test it messenger but while
testing he does not want to harm the
messenger he cannot see that the
messenger son dies while testing and
imagine now we have that the messenger
Jesus peace be upon him Himself is put
on the cross for somebody a citizen
it goes against Ezekiel chapter 18 verse
number 20 sin is not inherited if Adam
peace be upon him committed sin I will
not be responsible for this sin he has
committed and like an example if I give
you there's a master a rich person he
has many servants he tells the servant
don't do wrong things etc but yet the do
wrong things so he tells them since this
is my son I love my son and he kills
that son and then he faith all your
servants who used to rob we would
proceed now just believe that I killed
my son for your Robin and I will give
you salvation I will give your wages
does it sound logical the servants
robbed they cheap they caused loss to
the master master says nobody hears my
son I kill him don't change your style
just believe just believe that I killed
him for your sin and I forgive your sins
I'll give your wages daily it sounds
logical logical Almighty God putting
your own son and we don't degrees the
son will not grieve the begotten son as
a righteous person as a person of God we
agree if a Messenger of God in that
sense is the son of God but not the
Prachanda son of God hope damn son yes
brother further respected pressure and
in the Bible Gospel of Mark chapter 16
verse 17 and 18 it says and this signs
shall follow them that believe in my
name they shall cast out Devils they
shall speak with new tongues they shall
take up serpents and if they drink and
if they drink any deadly thing it shall
not harm them now if this is true can
you bring this poison or deadly thing
because according to me
it would surely harm you but as you are
a believer it should not harm you can
you prove this to us by drinking it
anyway it if it anything happens it we
are not responsible for it yeah see it
is written in context or people serving
the Lord and there are times like it
happened in China and Russia people were
forced to take poison in that context
not in the context making fun of God in
that context you will have the power
over these kind of things so in the
context of make a believer if you are a
believer nothing should happen to you
not just you're a believer in a context
of serving the Lord and not in the
context of making fun of God so you know
you have put forward your question let
the speaker respond in the manner he
wants your question is over you can hold
your bottle and send them without
speaking yes brother it is written
concerning Christ if he falls he will
not break his leg the angels will
protect him Satan wanted him to jump and
prove it
he said no don't tempt God I give you
the same answer don't tempt God the next
question from the ladies section for
doctors are kill any question yes zakir
naik my name is Ezra and I would like to
ask a question that question of Jesus
peace be upon him being crucified or
dying only arises for the sin of
humanity humankind only arises if he is
gone what is the concept of divinity of
Christ in Islam and Christianity this is
a very good question I just like to
comment on the earlier answer that
pastor if and I'd like to come rise with
him he said in his talk that Jesus
Christ peace bear wonders miracles and
from this your faith increases and when
he came to Bombay he had a disease like
spondylitis and I know being a doctor
it's a very serious disease and Jesus
Christ peace be upon him healed him and
he has a pamphlet on that Jesus guys
gave life to a girl he said now I think
it's faith has gone down he doesn't want
to have the poison maybe faith has gone
down if you believe
the poison his faith has gone down and I
congratulate him he's coming back to his
original faith that is Islam and he
describes upon him said in the Gospel of
Matthew chapter number 24 verse number
24 it says for they shall arrive many
false Christ's and false prophets and
they shall show wonders the miracles and
if it was possible shall deceive the
very elect miracle is not the test to
prove that you are divine or not that
you are a man of God or not that whether
you have faith or not according to Jesus
peace be upon him
sistahs very good question that what is
the concept of divinity of Jesus peace
be upon him and his salmon Christianity
again one was insufficient
so ramada chap number five verse number
72 it says look at cultural design a
column in the law who are massive new
marry me they are doing cuff they are
blaspheming those who say jesus peace be
upon him the son of mary is a las manos
allah Bakar al maseeh but said Christ
yeah when he's right Oh children of
Israel with Allah worship Allah Rob
you've become who's my Lord and your
Lord in no Mirabella and anyone no 30
partners with Allah Karim Allah lianna I
love will make the knot Haram for him
mama who non-valid lives almond and sod
and five shall be is dwelling place and
he shall have no helpers in the year
after
if you are so dead partner with Allah if
you say Jesus is Allah then that is
haram for you no salvation for you what
does Christianity say as I said there is
not a single unequivocal statement in
the complete Bible where Jesus Christ
peace be upon him himself says that I am
God already says worship Me
I challenge any Christian in Carina
pastor to show any unequivocal statement
a complete Bible where Jesus Christ
peace be upon him himself says that is
God already says worship Me
they can be certain statement which can
be assumed but in context is verified in
fact Jesus says it's mentioned the
Gospel of John chapter number 14 most
number 28 my father is greater than I
Gospel of John chapter number 10 was
number 29 my father is greater than all
gospel of matthew chapter number 12 was
number 28 I cast out devils with the
Spirit of God
Gospel of Luke chapter number 11 was
number 20 I cast out Devils
the finger of God Gospel of John chapter
number 5 was number 30 I can of my own
self through nothing either your I judge
and my judgment is just four and six not
my will but the milk of my father
if anyone who says not my will but God's
will he devotion and Jesus before all
the Muslim not my will but the will of
Almighty God he said in the Gospel of
John chapter 14 verse 24 the words that
you heard are not mine but my father who
I sent me Gospel of John chapter number
17 verse number 3 this is live eternal
so that you may believe in Almighty God
and Jesus Christ whom how I said it is
mentioned in the book of Acts chapter
number 2 verse number 22 that the other
Israel Jesus of Nazareth a man approved
of God from amongst you by wonders and
miracles which God did by him and your
witness to a man approved of God amongst
you by wonders and miracles which God
did by him so Jesus Christ peace be upon
him he never claimed divinity he was one
of the mightiest messengers of Allah
subhanAllah folk dances wish to thank
you maybe have the next question from
the ladies section for pastor Rockne
believing in crucifixion or resurrection
is the only way for salvation and if
Jesus died for the sins of humankind
then how will the people who lived
before Jesus attained salvation
this is very important topic it is
mentioned in many parts of the Bible
something which have an answer to this
the cross is central in history the
Christian looked behind 2,000 years ago
have faith in Jesus timeless they are
saved because of their faith in Jesus
the believers before Christ Abraham and
all the famous faithful people they look
forward by faith they were prophets they
look forward by faith to the times of
Jesus they have faith in Him and
therefore they are saved it is mentioned
that when they died because of their
faith in Christ of the future then Jesus
will he died one of the first things he
did he went down whenever they were kept
captives and he set them free because
they died in faith they could not go to
heaven because the price for this thing
was not yet paid but they were kept safe
in custody some spiritual place and
Jesus went down the deep places and set
them free and when Jesus died on the
cross many so tunes of holy men of all
times open and they walked in Jerusalem
they saw them with their own eyes so the
the past-tense people look forward for
Christ in faith they were saved by the
act of Jesus on the cross the present
people that's myself and many others
look behind and they we are saved
because of our faith in Jesus the cross
is effect is timeless the cross is
timeless for past humanity future
humanity present humanity thank you yes
rather
yeah my name is idle talker and I'm a
student in the Upper Room Jesus appeared
in a form of spirit isn't this proof
that he died and was resurrected the
brother has posed the question that
Jesus Christ be upon him he appeared in
the form of the Spirit in the upper room
is in the proof that he died and
resurrected the worst according whether
is some Gospel of Luke
chap number 24 verse number 37 which I
gave in my talk and I described it says
that the disciples were terrified and
affrighted they supposed that he was a
spirit supposed they thought he was the
spirit it doesn't say that Jesus Christ
peace be upon him was a spirit and to
clarify the next few verses Jesus says
in the Gospel of Luke chapter 24
what's the matter e9n 40 he says that
behold my hands and feet it's I myself
handle me and see for a spirit has no
flesh and bones it was a mistake on the
part of the disciples they taught you
all the spirit which was clarified by
Jesus peace be upon him that you check
see my hands see my feet and we come to
know that I'm not a spirit so even a
point to that was it gives proof that he
did not die and he was alive body
proving he was not resurrected thank you
yes brother good evening brother ruling
I am going to ask you a simple question
but it is not from the subject because
you have not touched the subject at all
to my knowledge you have spoken about I
mean many things Bibles and the Paul's
teaching and everything but you have not
talked more than five minutes on the
subject so whatever you have spoken I am
going to ask the question on that only
you say Moses has written five books the
five books of Genesis Exodus Leviticus
numbers and Deuteronomy these were
written by Moses if Moses has written
the books how he would have said that no
one knows my death over against a dead
pair and Moses was 120 else how is it
possible so the person if the gasps do
you know that the Bible is not the
original English language returned Bible
it is from the Koine Greek and Arabic
Arabic it may be Hebrew Hebrew and
Aramaic it is that these are translation
the Bible is a translation so whatever
you have returned
something you are you said two angels
remove the stone there you have written
angels in the original gray it is a word
Zhen Zhen you are translated into angels
when it comes to the question of
disciples I mean John's there you said
disciples no you are playing with the
words now you tell me which version of
the Bible is a correct you have
different versions and what language is
the Bible expansion is I don't think it
is an English because if I am Alive
thank you brother
no no you put this question it's a very
sentence it is a very serious one here
because I have not understood anything
from the pastor about the subject
because he has spoken about the Moses
Jesus and these are that - I have tossed
the question accordingly you have to
relax the rules please so this is the
question I am going to ask you what
language is in the Bible
whether it is English or some other
language suppose you know if I am i
lying I am sharing this reading
something like past tense you have to
explain to me what language is that
hello hello oh yeah brother has a very
complicated question
one day we'll go for a chai wallah I
will sit together and discuss it
together it's a simple question
which version is a true version and what
longer Moses has spoken Moses being are
like I was brother he goes by - brother
let the audience decide whether the
answer is right or wrong or whether is
given the enough answer or not
brother you cannot be the judge alone
give me only two minutes brother you can
exit
he said Bible is the mirror Bible is
some way rather he said listen brother
we appreciate your enthusiasm we
appreciate your enthusiasm but you
should understand our rules
I will repeat brother
we appreciate your enthusiasm we
appreciate the answer given by brother
Rockne he said we'll discuss it with a
chai wallah
you're welcome he's he'll pay for it
also right brother rally okay ready
that's it may we have the next question
for dr. Zakir from the ladies side
assalamualaikum brother what is the
concept of Trinity and how is it related
to crucifixion f IX Iowa yes suppose a
very good question that what is the
concept of Trinity and how is it related
to crucifixion f IX Iovine thank you for
clarifying that that will be difficult
for me to answer again
it's not me to be a point and the
biblical viewpoint Quranic you won't be
drinking again Quran gives the answer
and so reminder chap number five was the
most seventy-three leopard culture
Lavina column in the la sala fusa lhasa
that they are doing cook
they are blaspheming those who say that
God is three in one that Miss Trinity
and in certain research after four was
one seven even says while after Kulu
selasa do not say Trinity this has
stopped it it's better for you well at
the cool selasa the opportunity is
mentioned in the Quran no less than 2/10